[Musique]
a strasbourg il ya au coeur de la place
kléber un immense arbre de noël
il a coûté cette année 225 mille dollars
canadiens mais dans les villes du canada
les dépenses payées à même vos taxes
elle coûte combien
[Musique]
à montréal il ya le fameux sapin et
comme depuis deux ans il est financé à
même des fonds privés on ne sait pas
combien ils coûtent par contre juste à
côté de l'hôtel de ville de montréal
il y à un sapin et il a coûté cette
année 25 1250 dollars nettement moins et
que celui de l'année dernière qui a
récolté 53 mille dollars
il faut savoir que d'une année à l'autre
les dépenses fluctuent beaucoup parfois
on achète de nouvelles décorations
parfois on réutilise les mêmes que
l'année dernière ce qui fait que d'un
arrondissement à l'autre
la facture varie beaucoup dans côte des
neiges notre dame de grâce par exemple
on a investi l'an dernier près de
soixante mille dollars alors que dans
mercier hochelaga maisonneuve c'était
plutôt 5000 dollar
ailleurs au canada et bien il ya la
capitale de l'île du prince édouard
charlottetown qui investit 20 mille
dollars dans des prairies à winnipeg il
s'appelle l'hôtel de ville ne rien
coûter puisqu'il s'agit d'un don par
contre la ville a investi pour améliorer
l'efficacité énergétique de ses lumières
de noël
ce qui fait que la ville de winnipeg
investie puis trois heures entre 175 et
200 mille dollars par année
d'autres villes ont une autre approche
edmonton a choisi par exemple d'investir
dans un éclairage permanent qui s'adapte
en fonction du temps de l'année les
décorations de noël supplémentaires sont
assumés par des organismes
communautaires des commerçants ou des
particuliers de la capitale albertaine
sur ce l'équipe ii l'a vérif vous
souhaite de joyeuses fêtes
[Musique]